اجراءات امنيه مشدده افرج عن رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان بعد حصوله
على كفاله من المحكمه العليا لمده اسبوعين
في القضيه التي تعرف بارض جامعه القادر
والتي اعتقل بسببها في التاسع من ايار
الماضي من قبل هيئه المحاسبه الوطنيه قرار
ربما يعتبرهم وايدوه انتصارا كبيرا ورد
اعتبار لاسيما وانه اعتقل من داخل هذه
المحكمه ودون توجيه منها بينما قد لا يعجب
هذا القرار الحكومه التي قالت في وقت سابق
ان عمران خان ينبغي ان يحاكم في القضايا
المرفوعه ضده والا يحظى بامتياز خاص به
قرار الافراج عن خان جاء بعد مداولات
ومشاورات واحداث عنف واحتجاجات شهدتها
معظم المدن الباكستانيه وهو ما دفع
الحكومه لنشر قوات الجيش في العاص وبعض
المدن لغرض استعاده النظام هذه ليست
القضيه الوحيده التي يحاكم فيها رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان فهناك اكثر من
100 قضيه اخرى مرفوعه ضده في عدد من
المحاكم الباكستانيه الاحتجاجات التي
شهدتها عدد من المدن الباكستانيه تسببت في
مقتل اكثر من عشره اشخاص واعتقال اكثر من
2000 متظاهر من انصار حزب خان بينهم
قيادات رفيعه من في الحزب هذا القرار ربما
يرى فيه البعض بدايه لانفراجه وعوده
الهدوء خاصه بعد ان عاشت باكستان ايام
اصيبه سمير النمري الجزيره اسلام اباد